en realidad por supuesto del tema
nuclear es complicado porque rusia es
una potencia nuclear yo creo que el tema
es más simbólico que otra cosa en
realidad la central de chernóbil está
protegido la central de origen soviético
con lo cual ruso de sobre de otro
simbolismo pero digamos la central de
chernóbil está protegida por un por algo
que técnicamente llamamos sarcófago que
es un edificio digamos que blinda lo que
hay adentro de la central de chernóbil y
yo creo que el objetivo de rusia no está
en la central sino lo que llama la zona
de exclusión que es una zona de 30
kilómetros a la redonda la central donde
está incluida por ejemplo la ciudad
donde vivían antes los operadores en
está que se llama prípiat y que es una
zona que les permite a los rusos
penetrar fácilmente
a ucrania desde bielorrusia como tú
dijiste está a menos de 20 kilómetros de
bielorrusia y a su vez está
relativamente cerca de que lleva 30
kilos a 100 perdón kilómetros de kiel
con lo cual en realidad el objetivo de
chernóbil es menos nuclear que logístico
para facilitar desde el norte de
bielorrusia la invasión
a la capital aquí en entonces en este
sentido de lo que esto nos habla se
puede decir que la capacidad de
chernóbil de producir energía nuclear no
es tan determinante en la avanzada
militar rusa no definitivamente no
porque de hecho chernóbil no genera
energía nuclear ya desde hace décadas
está cerrada y está digamos cubierta el
reactor 4 que fue el que tuvo el
accidente en 1986 cubierta por este
sarcófago lo que sí es importante tener
en cuenta es que ucrania tiene otras
centrales nucleares en operación tiene
cuatro centrales alrededor de su
territorio no cerca de esa zona pero
alrededor su territorio con 15 reactores
y eso sí está en operación están activos
y digamos esperaríamos que dentro de la
guerra se tomaran las que tengamos
dentro de la tragedia de la invasión se
tomarán las precauciones de no afectar
los reactores que por ahora están lejos
de la zona de conflicto y esos 15
reactores de los que usted nos habla que
tan relevante es en la producción de
energía nuclear en todo el mundo
no en todo el mundo
digamos quizás depende mucho cada país
es muy relevante para ucrania ucrania es
un país que depende mucho de la energía
nuclear y por lo tanto digamos depende
de que esos reactores operen para tener
energía educar es un país con digamos es
importante están dentro de los digamos
primeros lugares' realista en cuanto a
la proporción de energía nuclear dentro
de su matriz eléctrica el país que tiene
más energía no que dentro de su matriz
eléctrica precisamente francia que
también digamos debajo de francia eeuu
pero claro es un país con con una
importancia importante proporción de
energía nuclear dentro de su matriz